[Music]
so we're gonna hit you guys hard and
fast today uh because we're drunk and we
want to have a laugh and we're gonna go
straight into twitter hall of fame
twitter hall of fame
right
as we've been talking about kanye for
like the past two months first one
connie is a better man than me
i would have been asking ariana grande
what you're doing at 3am
that wyd yeah literally right wyd
quotations
at 3 a.m
100 that would have been me 100 percent
bro fam hundreds of me i feel like i've
thought about that already that's so
weird that you said that because i
genuinely feel like i've had that
thought oh that like if i was kanye i
would literally be in like ariana
grande's dm's bro i have to because you
have to clap back yeah
you can't have my sending your pictures
like i'm in bed with your wife
i just [ __ ] your wife how do you feel
your kids are in the two room two rooms
down
no how do you feel
no mom yeah i have to smash all of your
exes
all of them
father
may no woman find my husband attractive
in jesus name because i i don't have the
strength i came to enjoy myself
fam we've spoken about this one before
this is a woman by the way
moaning during 69 to avoid doing my part
yes i don't want to miss it yeah someone
[ __ ] made it
yes bro yes they all do it they all do
it um
as far as my universe is concerned as
soon as my character development is
concerned they all do it
character
development that's hilarious all right
next one my homie told this girl about
that he travels for work bro works at
domino's
man travels around the
around the postcode
my boss asked me where i see myself in
five years and i told him not here
and now i'm in and now i'm in a meeting
with hr
i knew we're going [ __ ] up when he
unfollowed me on spotify
[Music]
i don't even have a response for that do
the next one i don't have a response for
that one do the next one
right now there's a poor guy working so
so so hard to gather money and go and
spoil his cheating girlfriend i wish you
luck though
i am um
i worry for people who think of tweets
like that
i mean
i worry for people who have an outlook
on life
to to tweet that
he's because he's been through [ __ ] yeah
oh he's tweeting that
from experience i wish you luck though
yeah
what's wrong
tell me what's up yeah yeah sit down
what's wrong because the marital home is
it yeah who has you it's rocky right who
hurt you i finally enough
that who hurt you lying is i find it so
relevant
and because um the other day
i was cooking up um
my beef did you see on my story
from your favorite
yeah a short rib it took me four hours i
worked my ass off on it
with the red wine reduction
i went my ass off i put it on my story
yeah yeah yeah my dm like man i say
puree it's mashed potato
you're right no i'm be serious yeah yeah
because i'm trying to live my life
that's just [ __ ] beefy potato yeah
who had you
because you're upset yeah by my dinner
yeah
my dinner has riled you up so what's
wrong talk to you this is in fact this
is a no judgement zone yes what the [ __ ]
is wrong
because this is not this is not normal
behavior
the amount of dms i got
slated my my dinner
my dinner that i slaved over for me
people hate it was it banging
oh was it banging
yes it was bro
it was unbelievable i love you i love
bishop rip i saw i was like well played
because i know i know my way around a
short rib oh i bet you i know my way
around the strawberries i was like i
like that i bet
sailors all right
um
done that one okay it's crazy as it's
crazy how as a kid you could have had
the most traumatic night of your life
and still had to go to school the next
day
one million percent bro having a bad
night's sleep is not an option when
you're a kid it's not it's not an option
i remember when we were kids someone's
like fire alarm was broken okay i was up
till like four o'clock in the morning
and i had to be up at seven
that's it
unlucky you have to go you're going
school you can't
you're going school you've got no choice
as an adult you have every choice in the
world yeah you've got no choice as a use
it's so peak
this one sweetened me
social media be having me thinking if
she doesn't respond in five minutes
she's getting raw dogged by my arch
nemesis
fam
yes
yes i don't really have those thoughts
but sometimes when you know when you're
in the back of the yeah yeah yeah and
then you see the thing's red and you
just don't hear from them again you're
like
oh i swear wrong
i assume the worst yeah of course
everyone does everyone seems to it's
natural
my archenemicism
of all people
that's funny
can't trust a [ __ ] who sleeps
with their door open
facts i don't think i've ever slept with
my door open i see my door open do you
that's scary to me brother i'm not
that's basically open yeah like a
criminal could slide in like that
my door's always closed
even if i'm in yard alone always close
really always closed that's funny i
don't know i don't really think about it
you know why i think it is
random it's because i dry my towels on
my door okay so when i come out and
shower the door yeah yeah so you can't
really close it so i just push it and
then it just stays there so i'm used to
it being open but yeah if i had if i
always closed it then yeah having it
open would scare me i can't i can't
sleep with my door open a car
it's weird to me
it's
even my when i lived alone in my first
yard always closed fair play
random since you live in the mezzanine
does it ever scare you because your
window's on the mess side right yeah
yeah yeah does that ever skate someone
might just sneak in your window
no because
obviously nowadays during this
quote-unquote winter period i don't open
but during summer period not really
either you know because
i mean i live in many and i feel like
many people aren't go on
on what
in the place i live oh yeah you live in
the posh ends yeah yeah you come up in
life you live in posh no one really
is about it
look like it
your build from what i've seen your
building is is full of hipster [ __ ]
and gamers
am i wrong i don't know if to be honest
i do tick-tock dances a man i play games
until four o'clock in the morning is
what i've seen in your building
fair enough i was trying to rush exactly
no it's not possible yeah it's not
really not possible it's really not
possible i'm not gonna lie to you my
window will be open during summer no
one's raiding me it's not the door will
be open the back door yeah it's not
possible
this one was tweeted by my boy latif
dumbledore and professor xavier really
had people's children fighting criminals
that's true
that's so true so that's true
so true is unbearable this one
stung me go on the sight of arsenal fans
enjoying football again makes me feel
[ __ ] sick
fam they've won eight games on the
bounce
and i'm thinking
these men are gonna get champions league
and we're not
it's frustrating james they're playing
good football it's making me sick
yo
fam i don't know why we don't do it more
often but when you talk about football
it invigorates my soul bro you're so
passionate about it um i'll do a few
more i knew school was a scam when his
when i saw hispanics failing spanish
class
oh
this one spoke to me because
my mom is
is is cue for this one yeah you dodge
them you dodge your mom's belt and she
go and tell the whole family that you
tried to fight her
[Laughter]
bro that's hilarious
bro that's hilarious bro
this one about 17 man sent me this one
you may have seen it too because they
may have sent it to you as well
but this is more of an ick as well as a
twitter hall of fame yeah
just sauce just saw someone say they got
the egg from the way their boyfriend's
body flailed around when they got in a
car crash
you man
ladies
that's that's unacceptable
bearing in mind you're in the car as
well fam flailing too yeah you had the
the cognitive ability the ability to
forget what's happening around you look
at your man and see him dangling for his
life and for yuck
how dare you react
how are you going to let gravity
control you in that way that's what
she's thinking how can gravity control
you like you're not a man i read that so
many every time i read that i read that
they're thinking that to us yo
that's embarrassing that's so funny
that's so funny oh this one this one was
a good one as well i wonder how many
miles i've scrolled with my thumb
oh
that's a good tweet that's one of them
will those type of things
[ __ ] them girls
because even if it's one mile of
embarrassment yeah yeah yeah bro
why would i lie is my best lie
that's toxic behavior yeah toxic and
i've been there that's toxic behavior
my mum
ain't nobody more fake than your mum
when she has guests over
i think that's everyone's mom oh i think
that's oh he wants me oh it is
everyone's mom i remember one time i was
still working at grill in the market and
obviously at that time obviously
hospitality my mum
my mum doesn't necessarily sometimes
know what i do
but because i work in hospitality she
just thinks i know everything about
hospitality yeah you know so there's a
time where
i was still living in london still
working at green on the market
she had some friends over whatever and
she asked me to get some of her friends
some food from the kitchen i was like
okay whatever
i got them i can't remember where it was
and i got them all for my mom and
whoever it was at the time
i got them food or whatever and my mom
was vexed at me as soon as i gave her
the food she was like how can you give
me food on a cold plate don't you work
in hospitality i wanted to fight
everyone in that [ __ ] room
what does that even mean brother
nah how can you give me food big man nah
on a cold plate don't you work in
hospitality no no no no no she said
don't you work in the kitchen
that's how i know that's how i knew stop
she that's how i knew she knew nothing
about what i did
stop she just knew i worked in a
restaurant fam i couldn't believe it i
think that's not even everyone's smiling
everyone's parents i'm pretty sure for
the first
five years of my pt career my dad said
to people i was a physiotherapist
man saw pt i said physio
i'm pretty sure my dad just tell people
i'm physiotherapist
yo my uncle would bring me a blog how's
physio life going
you just have to blank it you just can't
be bothered you just have to blag it ah
parents don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]